saviez-vous qu'avant d'accueillir la
nouvelle star le Pavillon Baltard
ressemblait à ça un marché aux volaille
géant retour dans les années 60 les
Halles de Paris accueillent un
gigantesque marché composé de 12
pavillons aujourd'hui du plateau
Beaubourg la rue du Louvre de la rue
coquillière au quai de La Seyne c'est
presque un arrondissement de la capitale
qui est dévoré par les camions et les
marchandises 5000 tonnes par jour de
nourriture pour la ville dans 20 ans
plus de 10000 tonnes quotidiennement
ces pavillons sont construits dès 1850
par l'architecte Victor Baltard sur
ordre de Napoléon III et à l'époque ils
sont ultra modernes avec leurs ossature
en verre et en métal mais un peu plus
d'un siècle plus tard en 1969 le grand
marché parisien est transféré à Rungis
20 000 marchands font leurs adieux aux
Halles bientôt remplacés par une garde
de RER
pour démonter démolir et enlever les
2500 tonnes de fer de fonte de plomb et
de zinc qui constituaient les pavillons
de Baltard c'est le temps dont dispose
les deux sociétés de travaux publics et
de récupération qui sont devenus
propriétaires de la superstructure des
Halles par adjudication publique et pour
la somme de 395000 francs que vont
devenir ces matériaux une partie sera
réutilisée dans la construction les
pièces non récupérables reprendront le
chemin des fonderies d'où elles étaient
sorties il y a 116 ans les pavillons
sont réduits en ferraille et les pièces
détachées vendues à la foire à ferraille
de Nogent-sur-Marne tous les pavillons
exceptés un le pavillon numéro 8 le
pavillon des œufs et des volailles que
l'État décide de sauver et promet d'en
faire don à la commune qui acceptera de
l'entretenir ironie de l'histoire le
maire de Nogent-sur-Marne Roland
Nungesser cherche justement à construire
une salle de spectacle et il décide de
sauter sur l'opportunité
[Musique]
comme tout le monde mais j'avais besoin
j'avais un projet déjà depuis quelques
années un hall d'exposition pour ces
expositions au cas je viens de faire
allusion une salle des fêtes parce que
nous n'avions rien de convenable et je
sois peut-être très cher j'avais vu ça
de côté
notre candidature nous avons réussi à
obtenir du gouvernement l'octroi de
Malta vous savez que le gouvernement
payait à la fois le démontage le
transport et leur montage nous l'avions
en charge que les fondations une salle
de spectacle gratuite le Pavillon
Baltard est démonté et reconstruit à
l'identique en 1976 durée du chantier 5
mois seulement mais il y en a un qui
s'est réchapper de pavillon démonté avec
douceur boulon par boulon enveloppé dans
du papier de soie comme un bonbon on la
remonté près de la Marne à Nogent à côté
des guinguettes et des plonflons
l'ancien marché au volaille accueille
des expositions des spectacles et
devient même un plateau télé comme pour
l'émission musicale star de Michel
Drucker et ça n'est pas pour déplaire à
un certain Michel Berger la musique
d'aujourd'hui elle se fait danser en
gare et dans des dans des choses qui
sont complètement au départ des endroits
de fortune mais qu'on a ménage et c'est
complètement le principe là et je crois
que Walter c'est vraiment un des
exemples d'endroit où on a envie de
faire de la musique Baltard c'est aussi
des meetings politiques comme le premier
meeting d'Edouard Balladur lors de la
présidentielle 1995 et dans un autre
registre le master de pétanque en 2006